[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verließ welt
heute gibt ein schokoladeneis mit
brownies eigentlich wollte ich heute was
ganz anderes machen da gucke ich ins
gefrierfach und sehe den ice bereiter
und ich dachte mensch ich habe dieses
jahr noch gar nichts mit dem eis
bereiter gemacht und vor allem gibt es
ja auch schon viele rezepte von mir mit
und ohne eismaschine aber ich werde
einfach immer wieder gefragt sally zeigt
heute was für den ice bereit
heute gibt's ein wir haben uns
einstimmig also wirklich alle nur alle
abgestimmt werden sagt braun
ich glaube von ben & jerry's gibt es
auch einen bogen sein
ich hab's noch nicht doch ich hab
sowieso mein gott es ist so gut mit so
half baked brownie stückchen drin und
deswegen die basis bildet jetzt einfach
mal ein braunes rezept ich habe das auch
schon online aber ich zeige es euch
trotzdem so im schnelldurchlauf machen
wir kurz die brownies und gehen dann
direkt an damit dass sowohl für die
brownies brauche ich 230 gramm butter
340 300 punkte bitterschokolade 50 gramm
kaffee den habe ich bereits rausgelassen
hier eine prise salz etwas von den
extrakt 200 gramm ihren 60 kam cacau 200
gramm gehackte haselnüsse und 100
compact wissen schoko jobs was ihr jetzt
zuerst macht ist ihr nehmt die butter
und zucker und die zutaten gibt der in
einen kleinen topf oder in eine schüssel
und erwärmt bis die butter geschmolzen
ist aber jetzt nicht kochen lassen also
jetzt nicht auf turbo hitze sondern
wirklich nur mittlere hitze und ich
werde schon mal den backofen vorheizen
auch 180 grad ober unterhitze und da
wollte ich auch mal zeigen wer die
teddys welt -app hat da kann praktisch
mit der renixx world of the box backöfen
serie a 8 einfach steuern
die sind ja auch wlan gesteuert das
heißt ihr habt auf dem handy in meiner
kostenlosen app die rezepte könnte um
rechnen könnt ihr im rechnungs funktion
benutzen und wirklich alles digital auch
um rechnen
da muss keiner mehr was selber machen
und dann geht ihr einfach die app klickt
das heutige rezept an
und dann könnt ihr einfach einstellungen
an den backofen senden und der ofen geht
von alleine am markt hat das mach ich
mal kurz das ist nämlich wie zauberei
und im prinzip das ist zwar nur ein
knopfdruck am backofen aber gerade wenn
man sich unsicher ist geht man einfach
in die app rhein kann sich einfach mal
alles einstellen und fertigt keine
einstellung keine temperatur und auch
keine backzeit also wie gesagt könnte
normalerweise auf des ellis welt app
gehen und wenn ihr zum beispiel rezept
auswählt das von heute habe ich jetzt
natürlich noch nicht angelegt weil ich
noch nicht fertig bin aber dann habt ihr
ja hier unten drin
einstell wetter in den ofen senden
klickt hier dran
die einzelwerte 170° usw jetzt starten
ich brauch jetzt 180 deswegen stelle ich
das jetzt ein aber wie gesagt sobald ich
dieses rezept angelegt habe in meiner
app könnt ihr einfach fremd stadt eben
aktivieren am backofen und dann alles
einstellen und es hat jetzt nicht nur
den vorteil dass er nichts einstellen
ist sondern wenn jetzt zum beispiel
wisst ihr seid jetzt gerade unterwegs
ich holte hat zum beispiel vom
kindergarten ab dann kann ich ganz
einfach vom handy aus dem ofen starten
und bis wir dann da sind in 20 minuten
ist das essen zum beispiel fertig also
hat schon gute vorteile oder ich kann
den ofen vorheizen wenn ich weiß ich
pack gleich was und ja das ist macht ihr
dann also hier lasse ich jetzt die
zutaten schmelzen
aber wie gesagt nicht kochen so lange
kann ich schon mal marimba kramen
aufstellen
nur leider das alte modell beim neuen
modell habt ihr nämlich die skalierung
dann aber der morath da ist zurzeit
immer im schock und der bug dort ganz
viel und hat einfach die sachen von hier
mitgenommen als hätte ich nichts im shop
das muss ich mir kurz aus müssen aber
wie gesagt v2 serie der hat einfach
direkt
die skalierung mit drauf da kann man
ablesen also 30 mal 20
wobei ich guck mal vielleicht stelle ich
ihnen später noch größer ein damit die
brownies nicht ganz so hoch werden
denn fürs als größer da jetzt hier
einfach den herd ausschalten und
schokolade einrühren und gerne auch den
warmen kaffee oder espresso und jetzt
einfach kurz rühren bis die schokolade
geschmolzen ist
jetzt fragen bestimmt einige war es gar
nicht statt kaffee nehmen wenn ihr den
kaffee nicht wollen lasst ihn einfach
weg
das wirklich so eine kleine menge da
macht es dann auch nichts aus wenn ihr
ihn nicht ersetzt ansonsten nehmen dir
einfach ein bisschen milch stopp dessen
schokoladen mischung ist es nicht heißt
sondern wirklich nur noch lauwarm
da die schokolade ja kalt war und
sozusagen die butter daneben
heruntergekühlt hat deswegen kann ich
jetzt auch hier direkt die eier
dazugeben und einrühren braucht nicht
nur eine schüssel also so einen report
kuchen dann das salz dazugeben
ich wollte da kennt man den extrakt
wollte tom kommt
ich glaube ich habe keinen bock mehr
deswegen nehme ich von kabul dem
tonkabohne im plan ist schon gut
ich kreis hier heute in der küche rung
also ok als ältere nimmt die vanille
extrakt wasserlöcher ist oder in dem tom
kha banker oder eine tonkabohne die wird
rein gegeben
bei tomtom gehabt da einfach den vorteil
ihr könnt nicht überdosieren denn so
eine tonkabohne ist im prinzip wie der
muskat muss oder auch sind giftig wenn
man einfach zuviel dosiert also zu viel
verwendet deswegen wirklich nur ganz
wenig nehmen und eben ganz fein reiben
da gebe ich jetzt das mehl und
kakaopulver dazu ist vorsichtig ein
und zwar so vorsichtig das keiner sagen
kann ich hätte der größere schüssel
nehmen sagen
darauf jetzt nicht kleckern denn da los
er hat gesagt er wartet nur auf den
moment auch das riecht so gut der kaffee
schmeckt mal übrigens nicht raus aber
ich finde da bringt einfach so oder so
eine geschmacksnote noch mit rein und
deswegen nehme ich ihnen ganz gerne mit
jetzt hier die gerösteten haselnüssen
die sind schon gehackt und nicht
gezuckert also das ist kein krokant zum
es jetzt so süß und debug festen schoko
jobs die sind zart bitte jetzt nochmal
vorsichtig das ist nämlich noch ein
junger rührlöffel sonst
es ist absurd
[Musik]
mutter was war der leitspruch das beste
zwischen zwei knusprigen wache messer
gefunden aber es war doch auch so
schokocreme unter diese gerösteten
haselnüssen und du hast gedacht aber
jetzt muss ich in den fernseher
reinweißen ok schreibt mir mal in die
kommentare so die werbesprüche die euch
so auf knopfdruck bei einer werbung
einfallen so was wie keine ahnung globus
da ist die welt noch in ordnung
einmal hin alles drin so sachen jetzt
habe ich hier den teig dann fühle ich
direkt in die backform 1
[Musik]
ja
sieht es vielleicht jetzt aber noch auf
blech größer aus denn ich möchte später
kleine braune würfel
ich glaub dass sie dann besser aus und
sie backen auch schneller wissen zu
dieser momente die mich dann nicht
glücklich machen
sich so ein blech vollbrand eick
klettert
[Musik]
jetzt kommen brownies in den backofen
die backzeit verkürzt sich jetzt
natürlich und die brownies wir brauchen
auch keine stäbchen provident sie sollen
ihnen noch matschig sein also wirken zu
half baked und dann sind sie perfekt
[Musik]
schaut mal 15 minuten waren perfekt die
sollen wirklich noch so ein bisschen
matschig sein lancierte kurz abkühlen
und kamen in der zwischenzeit schon mal
das schokoladeneis zubereiten denn das
ist auch selbst gemacht und das wird
super lecker und dafür nehme ich diese
zutaten 3 eigelb 150 gramm zucker 430
gramm cacau 100 gramm zarter schokolade
etwas vanille extrakt eine prise salz
200 gramm sahne 50 gramm verkauft
accounts das ist die ursprüngliche
schokolade
das heißt einfach gebrochene kakaobohne
in von siegbert da wird daraus dann
cacau hergestellt kakaobutter und die
sind wirklich mega lecker und sorgen
später im eis bilden krank denn ich
möchte das eis abstand schon haben habe
ich mir gedacht okay
als allererstes verhör ich jetzt die
eigelbe ich bin hier nach drüben
gewandert dennis auch gleich an den herd
ich werde die eigelbe mit dem zucker
schön cremig rühren und kann aber auch
schon mal die milch erwärmen
mit cacau
einfach so bei mittlerer stufe und hier
schön weiß cremig schon da gebe ich auch
schon was salz dazu
[Musik]
ich muss sagen normalerweise würde ich
jetzt da einfach die küchenmaschine
nehmen weil es schneller geht und ich
hab die hände frei ich wollte das rezept
aber so ein bisschen facebook halten
denn es hatte mich jeder der
küchenmaschine
ihr könnt aber wenn ihr kein wort
cooking chef habt oder auch die
kitchenaid mit dabei waren die burschen
sind auch damit arbeiten
denn die eigene masse wird jetzt im
prinzip weiß cremig geschlagen und
neugier zu einem handrührgerät und die
masse wird später auch noch erhitzt von
daher ist es eigentlich auch ganz
praktisch die maschine zu benutzen
[Musik]
was ich ja auch schon dazu geben kann
ist dass man in der extrakt passt auch
perfekt schokoladeneis und sobald hier
die masse lauwarm ist also etwas wärmer
als laut schon so 60 70 grad
ich kann mich schon wie schokolade
einrühren
was für meine hände waren für andere
hände heißt ich werde deswegen jetzt
nicht mehr einstecken können sie die
schokolade ein römisches ausgedacht oder
wie viele fälle es lauwarm
jedem schokolade schmelzen lassen und
ich arbeite wirklich auf sei niedriger
stufe soll nicht kochen ich hier weiter
cremig rühren
[Musik]
also jetzt wieder bei diesem thema
kannst du mit der einen hand nach rechts
drehen und die andere macht das kann ich
nicht falsch
jetzt rächt und da kann ich auch rechts
und links hoch aus und ich kann auch so
nicht mehr noch so aber ich kann jetzt
nicht hier und hier sind streifen
kreisteil kreis kreis 33 es geht nicht
weiter in 45 auf diese ich kann es nicht
aber es gibt menschen die können so war
okay da haben wir da die schokolade hat
sich aufgelöst hat mich eigentlich gut
wenn ich diese frau sich einließen
denn sich denn ich weiß sondern nur warm
wenn sie zu heiß ist dann steht nämlich
für ein
[Musik]
ich wollte gerade sagen so hey wie gehts
hier aus sind es mache einfach weiter
und dachte mir das ist nicht meine art
ich kann es gar nicht und ob es da vorne
jetzt habe ich hier die shop rohmasse
die kommt jetzt wieder zu verbinden top
machtvolle sind neben talk zu rücken
wenn du ein extremes jetzt wird die
masse so ein bisschen ein gedicht ist
auch nicht kochen lassen sondern er so
auf 80 grad ungefähr erhitzen das heißt
für alle geht kein thermometer besitzen
oder keinen perfekt oder keine
küchenmaschine mit diese funktion
einfach so etwa 23 minuten man erwärmen
damit pro hitze und dann reicht uns das
auch schon aber wenn ihr gerätschaften
und technische hilfsmittel benutzt so
ruhig dann müsst ihr nicht dastehen und
ständig spüren sondern können einfach
die maschine rühren lassen
ich mache es jetzt hier einfach mit dem
perfekt cook sensor und ich kann den auf
stufe 1 auf 70 grad einstellen stufe 2
auf 90 grad
ich habe es hier einfach stufe 1 warte
auf die 70 grad und dann erwärmt es
einfach noch ein bisschen tun hat so
80 aber wie gesagt 23 minuten erwärmen
das ist leicht eindeckt das reicht dann
auch
[Musik]
fatimas die perfekte temperatur und
vielleicht noch zum hintergrundwissen
man muss das erhitzen damit man einfach
ein schönes cremiges eis bekommt hat
auch den vorteil dass zum beispiel
salmonellen die auf der eierschale lage
neben auf getötet werden durch das
reißen der eimasse aber eigentlich macht
man es wirklich nur damit eiscreme ich
wird denn wird es nicht erhitzt wird
einfach nicht cremig wird es zu stark
erhitzt also koch die masse bereits dann
gewinnt ja das ei und dann verliert
einfach diese cremige eigenschaft und
jetzt können wir denn holzlöffel test
machen
also wie gesagt bei mir ist alles super
und jetzt nehmen wir einen löffel nicht
vielleicht auch mit einem anderen luft
funktionieren und ihr nehmt so ein
bisschen von der masse also ich sehe es
eigentlich schon ist noch zu flüssig
aber ich zeige euch mal wenn ihr drauf
pustet entstehen praktisch keine wellen
sondern die masse neigt sich einfach zur
seite
jetzt lasse ich noch ein bisschen
erwärmen aber wie gesagt kochen gab es
nicht denn sonst ist die binde
eigenschaft auch wie schön geduldig
schaut mal jetzt ist das dickflüssiger
jetzt will ich die masse hier denn die
muss jetzt erstmal abkühlen
so kann ich sie noch nicht in die
eismaschine stecken wer einfach noch zu
heiß und außerdem fehlt hier noch meine
sahne
die gebe ich jetzt einfach auch noch
dazu die kühlt das ganze jetzt auch
schon mal ab und ich lasse das jetzt
erstmal bei raumtemperatur abkühlen gibt
es da noch in den kühlschrank damit die
eismasse schön kalt ist und die caps die
kommen erst später dazu wenn das
geschehen ist
ich werde mein 1 bereit aufzubereiten
das hat den vorteil dass ich innerhalb
von 20 bis 30 minuten sondern es hat und
ich muss nicht ständig rühren wenig
keinen als bereiter habt gebt ihr dieses
eis also die eismasse eine flache auf
lokale zum beispiel geht es ins
gefrierfach und rührt dann ungefähr jede
stunde oder jede halbe stunde mal durch
damit eben auch cremig wird bei mais
bereiter ist jetzt nur wichtig hier das
reinsetzen
das passt und dann das eis erst rein
geben wenn es schon rührt ansonsten
friert nämlich das regiment fest
[Musik]
das heißt bereiter gibt es zum beispiel
auch für die kenwood oder auch ein
alleinstehendes bereite aber wie gesagt
geht es gab es auch ohne aber so weshalb
schon richtig schön cremig und ich laufe
das eis schon mal gefrieren und werde in
der zwischenzeit die brownies schon mal
in kleine würfel schneiden und die caps
die gebe ich dann aber erst muss das so
wenn es wirklich schon gefroren ist
jetzt also einfach der evag barmen lösen
mit einem back vom messer geht es ganz
gut
und dann die back folie wegziehen und
die braune sind kleine würfel schneiden
ich glaube mit dem bissig netz klappt
das auch
ich hoffe es
[Musik]
am ende greift durch
ich bin jetzt arbeite nur das halbe
blech schneiden oder sogar nur im
drittel
denn das übrige hier benutze ich zum
anrichten des vierten brown ideye brown
ideye eis drauf ist also wirklich
unseren dritteln benutzen und den
restlichen braune dann zum servieren
du musst mal probieren man nicht dass
die boni ist jetzt nicht schmecken und
dann haben wir den salat
wir können weitermachen
da muss noch mal
ich glaube wir müssen wir auch nicht
aufessen
ok jetzt warten wir auch seit die
braunen stückchen die frisch aber schon
mal ein
dann sehen wir schon mal kalt es sieht
gut aus
[Musik]
das eis sieht die ganze chance ich habe
jetzt hier die braune stücke ich nehme
jetzt einfach so einen teller und tiefen
großen haben sich vorher einfrieren
sollen
guckt euch dieses ist das lecker einem
fehler dürften niemals machen niemals
mit scharfen gegenständen in den ice
bereiter rein und niemals das eis im eis
bereite einstimmen man muss es einfach
rausnehmen dient einfach dem schutz des
ice bereit hat dass die oberfläche nicht
zerstört wird
wirklich schön mit einem tragschrauber
arbeiten
das ging jetzt schon relativ schnell gar
20 minuten
ein anschalten fertig das ist lass ich
mal dazu probieren jetzt hier um 5 ich
sehe doch ganz toll cremig und entweder
nimmt ist jetzt so schon als softeis das
kommt auch auf die außentemperatur an
unsere küche ist immer ziemlich warm
weil ich einfach ganz viele öfen
gleichzeitig an habe daher kann es auch
sein wenn ihr im hochsommer eis macht
das ist einfach noch ein bisschen länger
einfrieren müsst jetzt aber nicht
schlimm es war es so jetzt schon 14
bereit
aber ich habe es jetzt ganz gerne dass
ich wirklich mitten im eis portionierer
auch kugeln abstechen kann
hier kommen jetzt die kakao nix rein für
den kraftwerksbau
ich glaube ich vermisse jetzt noch gar
nicht das mache ich später ein paar hebe
ich mir auf für stopping und jetzt kommt
in den gefrierschrank wird von stunde
noch mal und dann problem wer also was
sie über das eis wissen müsst ist da
sind ja keine konservierungsstoffe drin
keine emulgatoren ästhetischen eis was
man auch wenn es aus dem gefrierfach
kommt ziemlich zeitnah verfahren sollte
und ich werde jetzt diese braunes noch
nehmen
oh mein gott sie sind so schön und das
ist der untergrund fürs eis und alleine
beim brownies schneiden und läuft mit
der das wasser im mund zusammen denn die
sind halt wirklich so
guck dir das aber so richtig doch haben
sie haben ja ich glaube ich muss
tatsächlich lasse für das bild muss ich
gleich so 2 über hunde machen jetzt und
hier
und zeige
familienmensch was ich lass dich
probieren darf ich so mein ding
jetzt darf ich so
okay ist oft gleich entweder auf deinen
scheiß oder auf 10 fuß mit diesen
braunisch stückchen oh mein gott muss
doch sagen oh mein gott es ist wirklich
so ich wollte euch auch bewegen
der wahnsinn hier
ja mein laptop
und
es ist schon brot gab also ich muss
sagen persönlich finde ich natürlich auf
dem brunni dann ist dann ist man schon
mächtig aber optisch deshalb mega aus
auf den boden
deswegen probiert's unbedingt mal aus
bereitet das braun
ich werde jetzt gleich wieder einführen
und dann können wir uns gleich an noch
mal eine kugel
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen schreibt mir gerne wenn ich
eine weitere eiskreationen machen soll
und schreib mir auch gerne eure wünsche
also bis zum nächsten mal
sie starb die kleine samira wird sagen
auf details waldmeister eis war mein eis
aus meiner kindheit da habe ich immer so
waldmeister kugel auf so einer waffe und
dann diese fest werden die schokolade
also in kuba töre und dann wird die so
fest und möchte so rein und habe dunkle
schokolade und dann diesen giftgrünen
waldmeister kern und ich denke das war
mein mainz
[Musik]